女嘉宾:起事
Female Guest: Start
Lucia:起
Lucia: Start
Lucia:这是咱今天晚上保留节目吗
Lucia: Is this our special program for tonight?
刘婷:这是我们的
Liu Ting: This is ours
Jack: 可以是可以是
Jack: It can be, it can be
Lucia:可以是可以是
Lucia: It can be, it can be
Jake: 挺好挺好的
Jake: Pretty good, pretty good
Lucia:来我帮你拍
Lucia: Let me help you take it
刘婷:AI识别不出来了怎么办
Liu Ting: What if the AI can't recognize it?
Jake: 最好让它识别出来对
Jake: It's best to let it recognize it, right
Lucia:这个怎么
Lucia: How is this
Lucia:现在就是开了
Lucia: Now it's on
Lucia:你要不要先调一下这些各种 参数之类的这些
Lucia: Do you want to adjust these various parameters first?
刘婷:然后我们前面有两个人
Liu Ting: And we have two people in front
Jack: 我看看没什么需要调的
Jack: Let me see, nothing needs adjusting
Jack: 然后你就看你喜欢的背景就可以了
Jack: Then just look for the background you like
Lucia:行行你你有没有啥喜欢的背景
Lucia: Okay, okay, do you have a favorite background?
Lucia:你来选择
Lucia: You choose
Lucia:或者你刚刚就是帮大家拍的时候
Lucia: Or when you were just taking pictures for everyone
Lucia:你觉得哪里好看你就站哪里就行
Lucia: Wherever you think looks good, just stand there
Katrina:  还没怎么去了解呢
Katrina: I haven't really checked it out yet
Katrina:  我应该是做容器那一块
Katrina: I should be doing the container part
Jake: 好大劲啊
Jake: Such a big effort
Katrina: 也就容器那一块
Katrina: Just the container part
Lucia:你是换了个镜头吗
Lucia: Did you change the lens?
Jack: 没有啊如果你
Jack: No, if you
Lucia:是调焦啊ok 了
Lucia: It's focusing, okay
Lucia: OK OK来试试吧
Lucia: Okay, okay, let's give it a try
刘婷:左
Liu Ting: Left
Jake: 我就不试
Jake: I'm not trying
Lucia: 不是他咋又黑了
Lucia: Why did it go dark again?
Lucia: OK OK OK
Lucia: Okay, okay, okay
刘婷:起 右 左
Liu Ting: Start, right, left
Shure的女友:OK啊我回家
Shure's GF: Okay, I'm going home
Shure的女友:我带个小朋友回家
Shure's GF: I'm taking a kid home
刘婷:左右踏步
Liu Ting: Step left and right
Shure的女友:然后回家之后我妈说我就知道
Shure's GF: Then when I got home, my mom said I knew it
Alice: 这不是踏步
Alice: This isn't stepping
Shure: 吓死我以为你说小朋友是是我
Shure: Scared me, I thought you meant the kid was me
Lucia:为啥是连拍
Lucia: Why is it on burst mode?
其他人：你把高速连拍开了
Lucia: 拍了好多张
Lucia: Took so many shots.
Katrina: 这光要开闪光灯吗
Katrina: Do we need to use the flash for this light?
Alice:在哪
Alice: Where is it?
Lucia:这个光感好像不太用
Lucia: This lighting might not need it.
Katrina: 如果想让脸要亮一点的
Katrina: If you want the face to be a bit brighter.
男嘉宾:脸亮点可以还行
Male Guest: A bit brighter on the face would be fine.
Lucia:就是这样感觉还行
Lucia: Yeah, this feels okay.
男嘉宾:可以开一下闪
Male Guest: You can turn on the flash.
Jack: 可以看一下闪
Jack: You can check the flash.
刘婷:拍这哎
Liu Ting: Shoot this, hey.
Jack: 但是这个
Jack: But this...
Jack: 但是这个它本体是不带闪光灯的
Jack: But this one doesn't have a built-in flash.
Lucia:雨轩看一下
Lucia: Yu Xuan, take a look.
男嘉宾:你没有你没有闪是吗
Male Guest: You don't have a flash, right?
Jack: 显然没有哦
Jack: Obviously not.
Lucia:哦没按
Lucia: Oh, didn't press it.
刘婷:然后对对对
Liu Ting: Yeah, right, right.
刘婷:他们归位之后就左右哈哈哈
Liu Ting: After they get back in position, just left and right, haha.
Lucia: 要再来一张吗
Lucia: Want to take another one?
Lucia: 你看你想站哪
Lucia: See where you want to stand.
Jake: 哎你干嘛呢自闭啦
Jake: Hey, what are you doing, sulking?
Alice: 猫眼三姐妹
Alice: The Cat's Eye Sisters.
Lucia:我说那边OK
Lucia: I said, that side is okay.
Alice:我再记一会
Alice: I'll remember it later.
刘婷:背过去
Liu Ting: Turn around.
Alice:背过去
Alice: Turn around.
Alice:起 起事 右 左 右 左 踏步
Alice: Start, start the move, right, left, right, left, step.
男嘉宾:看来她们后面要跳舞
Male Guest: Looks like they're going to dance.
男嘉宾:让他把这张帘放下他们后面会动
Male Guest: Let him lower the curtain, they'll move behind it.
Lucia:对对对我也想说
Lucia: Yeah, yeah, I was thinking the same.
Lucia:你这个入镜的刚好都是些可乐和酒
Lucia: Your shot just happens to include some cola and alcohol.
Lucia:显得你特别像一个调酒师或者什么的
Lucia: Makes you look like a bartender or something.
男嘉宾:啊可以可以
Male Guest: Ah, that's fine.
Lucia:刚好
Lucia: Just right.
Katrina:  这一块还有挺有氛围感的
Katrina: This spot has a nice vibe.
Lucia:是吧
Lucia: Right?
Alice: 哈哈
Alice: Haha.
刘婷:实在不行咱还是跳舞吧
Liu Ting: If it really doesn't work, we can still dance.
其他人:诶呀，我好呆呀
Alice:不行你太弱智
Alice: No way, you're too dumb. 社会问题
男嘉宾:我给你拍一个
Male Guest: I'll take a picture for you.
Lucia:你本来就这么呆
Lucia:哈哈不是我摄影技术问题
Lucia: Haha, it's not my photography skills.
Lucia:哈哈 跑了 哈
Lucia: Haha, you ran away. Haha.
Lucia:跑了相机不好相相机没拍出你的这个
Lucia: You ran away, the camera couldn't capture your...
Lucia:这个这个英姿飒爽是吧
Lucia: Your heroic spirit, right?
Lucia:哈哈哈 这咋 哎
Lucia: Hahaha, what the... hey.
Lucia:相机没拍出你的英姿飒爽
Lucia: The camera couldn't capture your heroic spirit.
刘婷:这不关你的事
Liu Ting: It's not your fault.
Alice: 啊这个哈哈哈哈
Alice: Ah, this... hahaha.
刘婷:这个哈哈
Liu Ting: This... haha.
刘婷:你就是天生练这个， 你就是这个苗子我天呢
刘婷:如何
Liu Ting: How is it?
Lucia:特别好
Lucia: It's great.
Alice:好像学会了又好像没学会
Alice: It's like you learned it, but also didn't.
Alice: 你你要不要参与我们
Alice: Do you want to join us?
Jake:早来一点 我靠
Jake: Come a bit earlier, geez.
Alice:脸 哈哈哈Lucia你来嘛
Alice: Haha, Lucia, come here.
Alice: 我是摸屁股这个
Alice: I was just patting the butt.
Alice: 哈哈哈不是哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha, no, hahaha.
Lucia:不行
Lucia: No way.
Alice:你是哈哈那个
Alice: You're the... hahaha.
刘婷:这是不是太近了
Liu Ting: Isn't this too close?
Lucia:如何一句话劝退别人是吗
Lucia: How to talk someone out of it in one sentence, right?
Jake: 让我整这个
Jake: Let me handle this.
刘婷:ok 来来来来
Liu Ting: Okay, come on.
刘婷:或者我们投票吧
Liu Ting: Or we can vote.
刘婷:就是可能会伤害他的眼镜
Lucia:伤害他的眼镜 啊 OK
Lucia: Hurt his glasses? Ah, okay.
Alice: 就这样蹦来蹦去吗
Alice: Just jumping around like this?
Alice: 我连个兜都没有
Alice: I don't even have a pocket.
Alice: 这别我腰上的
Alice: Tied around my waist.
刘婷:拿着  还有一个就是这个
Liu Ting: Hold this. And there's also this.
Lucia:啊 不过这个就是容易掉下来
Lucia: Ah, but this might fall off easily.
Alice:他抖音上全是这种低智小视频
Alice: His TikTok is full of these low-IQ videos.
刘婷:对像你
Liu Ting: Just like you.
Lucia:那刚那个人是你吗
Lucia: Was that person you?
刘婷:不是这是我网
Liu Ting: No, that's my...
刘婷:哦我网上收集的低智数据
Liu Ting: Oh, the low-IQ data I collected online.
Lucia:OK
Lucia: Okay.
Shure的女友:哦
Shure's GF: Oh
Alice: 低智太奶这就是
Alice: That's just low IQ granny
Shure的女友:不是
Shure's GF: No
Katrina:  这应该把富士带来
Katrina: We should have brought Fuji
Shure的女友:不是
Shure's GF: No
刘婷:就是他先起来
Liu Ting: He got up first
Katrina:  哦哦对
Katrina: Oh right
刘婷:然后我们后面剩下左右左
Liu Ting: Then the rest of us left, right, left
Alice:这样
Alice: Like this
刘婷:然后到位踏步
Liu Ting: Then in place, march
Lucia:迅速进入角色
Lucia: Quickly get into character
刘婷:你看你看
Liu Ting: Look, look
刘婷:无所谓拍的好不好无所谓
Liu Ting: Doesn't matter if it's well-shot or not
刘婷:重在参与好不好 重在参与
Liu Ting: Participation is what matters, okay? Participation
刘婷:有信心吗
Liu Ting: Are you confident?
Lucia:没有
Lucia: No
刘婷:没有我不
Liu Ting: No, I don't...
Shure: 嗨 这都是我们配的一环
Shure: Hey, this is all part of our collaboration
刘婷:你要有
Liu Ting: You have to be
Alice:有
Alice: Yes
Lucia:响亮的答案没有
Lucia: Loud and clear, no
刘婷:要有要有要有
Liu Ting: You have to be, you have to be, you have to be
刘婷:OK我们看一下我们看一下
Liu Ting: OK, let's take a look, let's take a look
Katrina: 我 我想
Katrina: I... I want to
Lucia:嗯
Lucia: Hmm
Jack: 你们准备好啦
Jack: Are you guys ready?
Katrina:  我想拿这个拍照
Katrina: I want to take a picture with this
Lucia:我们没有
Lucia: We don't have...
Jack: 可以啊
Jack: Sure
Jake: 你要变身
Jake: You need to transform
刘婷:你看一下位置
Liu Ting: Check your position
刘婷:这这这那
Liu Ting: This, this, this, that
Alice:那我不就是最明显的那个了
Alice: Then I'll be the most noticeable one
刘婷:我我我侧面侧侧过来侧过来
Liu Ting: I... I'll turn to the side, turn to the side
Alice:好
Alice: Okay
刘婷:侧过来就是我可以站稍微远一点吗
Liu Ting: Turning to the side, can I stand a bit further?
Jack: 这这黄哪光都那样
Jack: The lighting is like that
Jake: 可以打光要不要搬出来
Jake: We can light it up, should we move it out?
Jake:那我搬出来
Jake: I'll move it out then
Shure: 哦你记不记得人有次军训去男生宿舍那次
Shure: Oh, do you remember that time during military training when we went to the boys' dorm?
Jack: 那可以
Jack: That works.
刘婷:哎呦 不对哦
Liu Ting: Oh no, that's not right.
Alice: 那这边不就没地了
Alice: Then there won't be any space here.
刘婷:OK来看下准备
Liu Ting: OK, let's check the preparation.
Alice:行了吗
Alice: Is it done?
刘婷:OK差不多
Liu Ting: OK, almost.
刘婷:来来来
Liu Ting: Come on, come on.
刘婷:差不多然然后你咱咱分散开
Liu Ting: Almost, then you spread out.
刘婷:你左边一个
Liu Ting: You on the left.
刘婷:我右边一个
Liu Ting: I'll be on the right.
刘婷:你往那边走
Liu Ting: You walk that way.
刘婷:走一点点
Liu Ting: Just a bit.
Shure的女友:我们两个女生
Shure's GF: The two of us girls.
Lucia:这样
Lucia: Like this.
刘婷:对啊可以能拍到
Liu Ting: Yeah, we can capture it.
Alice:来吧
Alice: Come on.
刘婷:嗯 我想想嗯OK OK
Liu Ting: Hmm, let me think... OK, OK.
刘婷:我们先熟悉的伴奏好不好好
Liu Ting: Let's get familiar with the accompaniment first, alright?
Alice: 好
Alice: Alright.
Lucia:哇哦哈哈
Lucia: Wow, haha.
Alice: 我天天拍这种低智视频
Alice: I shoot these silly videos every day.
Alice:他的座右铭就是看低智视频
Alice: His motto is to watch silly videos.
Alice:想低智人生
Alice: And live a silly life.
Lucia:哈哈我以为是享高智人生呢
Lucia: Haha, I thought it was to live a high IQ life.
Alice:哈哈我以为是想高智人生
Alice: Haha, I thought it was to live a high IQ life.
Jack: 你们难道你们并不是
Jack: Aren't you guys?
Katrina:  我们太随便了
Katrina: We're too casual.
Lucia:先合并是吧
Lucia: Merge first, right?
刘婷:321
Liu Ting: 3, 2, 1.
Shure: 你叫我给你送笔
Shure: You told me to bring you a pen.
刘婷:开始
Liu Ting: Start.
Alice:是这样吗
Alice: Like this?
Shure的女友:no no no no
Shure's GF: No, no, no, no.
Lucia:然后下一个是我是吧
Lucia: Then the next one is me, right?
Lucia:啊这样子
Lucia: Ah, like this.
Lucia:然后还是接着动啊哈哈
Lucia: And then keep moving, haha.
Alice: 玩不了一点哈哈哈
Alice: I can't play a bit, haha.
刘婷:存个草稿
Liu Ting: Save a draft.
Alice:看看
Alice: Let's see.
Jake:我不会了
Jake: I can't do it anymore.
Jake: 他很便宜啊
Jake: He's really cheap.
Jack: 那就这样了
Jack: So, that's it then.
Jake: 好嘞 能强点是吧
Jake: Alright, it can be stronger, right?
Jack: 不是 色温可以重新
Jack: No, the color temperature can be adjusted.
刘婷:存草稿吧存草稿
Liu Ting: Save the draft, save the draft.
Alice:哎呦 我笑死了
Alice: Oh my, I'm dying of laughter.
刘婷:有信心吗
Liu Ting: Confident?
Lucia:没有
Lucia: No.
Alice:没
Alice: No.
Lucia:响亮的答复 没有
Lucia: A loud answer, no.
Alice:没有我们先休息一会
Alice: No, let's take a break first.
Alice: 不急于一时
Alice: No rush.
刘婷:行 没事
Liu Ting: Sure, no problem.
Alice: 反正有个草稿了
Alice: We have a draft anyway.
刘婷:我们
Liu Ting: We...
刘婷:我们有这一个版其实已经很不错了
Liu Ting: We already have this version, which is quite good.
Lucia:对
Lucia: Yes.
Alice:很不错了
Alice: It's really good.
刘婷:至少有勇气站在这舞台上了
Liu Ting: At least we had the courage to stand on this stage.
Alice: 确实如果你不在
Alice: Indeed, if you weren't here...
Lucia:这是从零到一的进步
Lucia: This is progress from zero to one.
Alice: 我是绝对不会站在这里丢人的
Alice: I definitely wouldn't be here embarrassing myself.
Alice: 但是我跟你一起丢人就没有
Alice: But if I'm embarrassing myself with you, then it's not...
刘婷:你特么
Liu Ting: You...
Alice: 就没有那么丢人
Alice: It's not that embarrassing.
刘婷:修饰一下你语言修饰一下你语言啊
Liu Ting: Watch your language, watch your language.
Alice: 羞耻
Alice: Shameful.
Lucia:怎么能这样呢
Lucia: How can you say that?
Lucia:说的好像我不愿意跟你一起丢人一样
Lucia: It's like I don't want to be embarrassed with you.
Alice:哈哈哈但是我不愿意拉你一起丢人
Alice: Haha, but I don't want to drag you into it.
Alice:但是她丢人的话我觉得就可以
Alice: 哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
刘婷:我受够了
Liu Ting: I've had enough.
Jack: 哎呀
Jack: Oh dear.
Jack: 这边是什么剧情啊
Lucia:等一下我手里有张纸
Lucia: Wait, I have a piece of paper.
Lucia:要不要比个心
Lucia: Wanna make a heart?
Lucia:我们俩这样
Lucia: Like this, the two of us.
男嘉宾：要在打点光效果更好
Male Guest: It would look better with some lighting.
Alice:背光了
Alice: It's backlit.
刘婷:你们眼镜上面有光
Liu Ting: There's a glare on your glasses.
Jack: 只有上眼镜上泛着诡异的光
Alice: 那那我们这样
Alice: Well, let's do this.
Lucia:眼睛上泛着诡异的光
Lucia: The glasses are reflecting a weird light.
女嘉宾:眼镜上面有光
Female Guest: There's a glare on the glasses.
Lucia:可还行 哪边
Lucia: Yeah, which side?
Katrina:  一起播
Katrina: Let's go live together.
Alice:来吧
Alice: Sure.
Katrina:  我们一起拍 拍拍
Katrina: Let's film together.
Lucia:可
Lucia: Okay.
Alice: 怎怎么摆
Alice: How should we pose?
Alice:比心
Alice: Heart sign.
Lucia:可以可以
Lucia: Sure, sure.
Lucia:交叉比等一下
Lucia: Cross and wait a moment.
Alice: 我是危险中心
Alice: I'm in the danger zone.
Lucia:手里一直揣着这个
Lucia: Holding this all the time.
Katrina: 我也加入
Katrina: I'll join too.
Lucia:刚才擦手用餐巾纸擦
Lucia: Wiping hands with a napkin just now.
Lucia:咱俩还可以这样
Lucia: We can also do this.
Lucia:算了有点乱了
Lucia: Never mind, it's a bit messy.
Alice: 有点抽象
Alice: It's a bit abstract.
Lucia:等一下我扶一下眼镜
Lucia: Wait, let me adjust my glasses.
Lucia:我这眼镜往下滑
Lucia: My glasses keep slipping down.
Katrina: 这光补光打出来啥样
Katrina: How's the lighting now?
Alice:累了
Alice: Tired.
Lucia:哎这个光很好
Lucia: Hey, this light is great.
男嘉宾：你可算 露西亚你可算有脸了
Lucia:有补光灯就是不一样
Lucia: Having a fill light makes a difference.
Katrina:  什么环节
Katrina: What segment?
Katrina:  现在是after party阿
Katrina: It's the after party now, right?
Lucia:after party
Lucia: After party.
Lucia:不是不是要不是修硕要唱歌来着吗
Katrina:  啊修硕 唱歌
Katrina: Ah, Shure, sing.
Lucia:不是修硕要跳舞来着的吗
Lucia: Wasn't Shure going to dance?
Jake: 对啊修硕跳舞唱歌
Jake: Yeah, Shure dances and sings.
Katrina:  修硕跳舞
Katrina: Shure dances.
Lucia:不是修硕要干好多事来着吗
Lucia: Wasn't Shure going to do a lot of things?
Katrina:  哈哈哈核心主力吗
Katrina: Haha, core performer?
Shure:  我怕回去他不认我了
Shure: I'm afraid he won't recognize me when I go back.
Katrina: 哈哈你跳个舞她也跟你和好了
Katrina: Haha, if you dance, she'll make up with you.
男嘉宾: 可以帮我们俩照一下吗
Shure:  哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha
男嘉宾: 你要在这是吗
男嘉宾: 对对
Shure的女友:哎 你别说他小时候学过
Shure's GF: Hey, don't say, he actually learned it as a kid.
Katrina:  他学什么舞种
Katrina: What kind of dance did he learn?
Shure的女友:你问他咯
Shure's GF: Ask him yourself.
Katrina:  不会学拉丁吧
Katrina: Did he learn Latin dance?
Alice:我去送他一下
Alice: I'll go see him off.
Jake:好
Jake: Okay.
Jake:没开过
Jake: Never opened it.
Katrina:  你再说他要破防要破防
Katrina: If you keep talking, he'll get defensive.
Jake:头回开
Jake: First time opening it.
Alice:开过 但忘了
Alice: He did open it before, just forgot.
Alice:那我就录着这个走啦
Alice: I'll just take this and go then.
Jake:好好好
Jake: Okay, okay, okay.
Alice:拜拜
Alice: Bye-bye.
Jake:拜拜拜拜
Jake: Bye-bye, bye-bye.
Katrina: 他要走了吗
Katrina: Is he leaving?
Lucia:哎 她们是
Lucia: Hey, they are...
男嘉宾: 再来一张吗
Katrina: 我们预计八点结束还没有开始唱一首歌
男嘉宾:Ok,看我一下，321
男嘉宾:自己看，我感觉还行
Katrina: 你还没表演你的才艺呢
Katrina: You haven't performed your talent yet.
Lucia:没事没事
Lucia: It's okay, it's okay.
Lucia:相信您的技术
Lucia: I trust your skills.
男嘉宾:哦，不错的不错的
男嘉宾:啊，挺好，挺好的
男嘉宾:嗯可以的
Lucia:哎我觉得这张很好对对对
Lucia: Hey, I think this one is great, right, right, right.
男嘉宾：对 我也觉得
Male Guest: Yeah, I think so too.
Lucia: 对对对
Lucia: Right, right, right.
男嘉宾:不看我好像显得冷静
Lucia:最后最后那张就是我
Lucia: The last one is me.
Lucia:就是那个角度的话
Lucia: From that angle...
Lucia:我的脸型会有点有点胖
Lucia: My face looks a bit chubby.
Lucia:但是前面几张都很好
Lucia: But the earlier ones are all great.
Jake: 别忘了那三首歌啊 我靠 哈哈哈
Jake: Don't forget those three songs, oh my god, hahaha.
Lucia:没事没事可以了
Lucia: It's okay, it's okay, it's fine.
Lucia: 谢谢谢谢
Lucia: Thank you, thank you.
Lucia:我觉得您拍得很好很好
Lucia:只有偶偶然有发挥失误的时候也很正常是吧
Lucia: It's only natural to have occasional slips, right?
Katrina: 一起唱呗
Katrina: Let's sing together.
Shure: 好
Shure: Sure.
Katrina: new boy这首
Katrina: "New Boy" this one.
男嘉宾:我告诉你，我最近发现一组情侣那种姿势，就是让我来试一下，你俩配合我一下
Shure的女友: 修硕 我们俩
Shure's GF: Shure and I...
Katrina: 模特模特
Katrina: "Model", "Model".
Shure: 收费啊收费
Shure: There's a fee, there's a fee.
Shure的女友:拍你们不行吗
Shure's GF: Can I take a picture of you?
Jack: 你俩是唯一正经的情侣
Jack: You two are the only serious couple here.
Shure: 什么叫正经
Shure: What do you mean by serious?
Shure: 你们这些回去都不能说是吧
Shure: You guys can't even talk about it when you go back, right?
Shure:  哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha
Lucia:我们这都不是CP
Lucia: We're not even a real couple.
男嘉宾:我们我们这桌算cp
Male Guest: We, our table counts as a couple.
男嘉宾:女生拿酒然后看着，男生看女生
Shure的女友:咦不要
Shure's GF: Ew, no.
Katrina:  我试试给你们拍一组壁纸出来
Katrina: I'll try to take a wallpaper photo for you.
Jake:两个ego币
Jake: Two ego coins.
其他人:你还让他们摆poes
Jake:蹲下去了这个就不行了
Jake: If you squat down, it won't work.
Shure的女友:呵呵sorry尊重摄影师好吗
Shure's GF: Haha, sorry. Please respect the photographer, okay?
Shure:  怎怎么看摄影师
Shure: How do we look at the photographer?
女嘉宾:怎么看
Female Guest: How to look?
女嘉宾:哈你
Female Guest: Haha, you.
男嘉宾:就你随便看个地方吧
Male Guest: Just look somewhere casually.
男嘉宾:没有入镜
Male Guest: Not in the frame.
男嘉宾:看地上然后你看啊
Male Guest: Look at the ground, then look up.
Katrina: 哈哈不准笑场
Katrina: Haha, no laughing allowed.
Shure的女友:就是我们俩这个情况比较复杂
Shure's GF: Our situation is a bit complicated.
Shure的女友:你知道吗
Shure's GF: You know?
Jake:啊
Jake: Ah.
Jack: 什么情况比较复杂
Jack: What's so complicated?
Jake:啊什么叫复杂什么叫复杂
Jake: Ah, what do you mean by complicated?
Jack: 什么叫复杂
Jack: What's complicated?
Katrina: 拍 拍 拍到非公开群里
Katrina: Take it, take it, and post it in the private group.
男嘉宾:哪里复杂
Male Guest: What's complicated about it?
Shure的女友:sorry
Shure's GF: Sorry.
Shure的女友:不是他看我我看他
Shure's GF: It's just, he looks at me, I look at him.
Jake: 你要给我们送一集多少信息
Jake: How many messages are you going to send us in an episode?
Shure的女友:我们俩会笑场
Shure's GF: We'll end up laughing.
女嘉宾:好看呐可以截一下
Female Guest: Looks good, take a screenshot.
Jack: 怎么复杂
Jack: How's it complicated?
Jake:咱能飙一下午咱能飙得了不
Jake: Can we keep this up all afternoon, can we?
Jack: 复杂在哪
Jack: Where's the complexity?
Jake:咱能飙得了不
Jake: Can we keep this up?
Lucia:可以选一下帧
Lucia: You can select a frame.
Lucia:因为那个动
Lucia: Because it moves.
Tasha: 好的好的
Tasha: Got it, got it.
Tasha: 好谢谢谢谢
Tasha: Okay, thanks, thanks.
Jack: 为什么复杂然后发给修硕他
Jack: Why is it complicated, then send it to Shure
女嘉宾：我们俩自拍一下我觉得这边光比较好
Female Guest: Let's take a selfie, I think the light is better here.
Lucia:可以啊
Lucia: Sure.
Lucia:眼睛会有点反光是
Lucia: The eyes might reflect a bit.
其他人：有点发光啊
Lucia:对是有点反光
Lucia: Yeah, there's some reflection.
其他人：你站我前面吧
Lucia:要不我来我来拿这个
Lucia: How about I hold this?
Lucia:然后
Lucia: Then...
男嘉宾:你俩能互相看一下吗
Male Guest: Can you two look at each other?
Lucia:这样看好像有点暗
Lucia: It looks a bit dark like this.
Lucia:等一下 这怎么老往下滑
其他人：可以
Katrina: 你俩别整的像暧昧气一样行吗
Katrina: Can you two not make it look so ambiguous?
Lucia:好的
Lucia: Okay.
Jack: 你们俩搞得像你们俩
Jack: You two are making it look like...
Lucia:可以可以可以选一下帧
Lucia: Okay, okay, choose a frame.
Jack: 所以是暧昧期吗
Jack: So, is this the ambiguous phase?
Lucia:这个我好像没有这两张我好像没有看镜头
Lucia: I think I'm not looking at the camera in these two.
Lucia:不过你可以选一下帧
Lucia: But you can choose a frame.
Lucia:我自拍的时候其实不知道应该看哪
Lucia: I never know where to look when I take a selfie.
男嘉宾:我也不懂我也很好奇
Male Guest: I don't get it either, I'm curious.
Jake:回去你自己标啊
男嘉宾:最后两张
Male Guest: The last two.
Jake: 哈哈哈 我是标不了的
Jack: 到正到时问起就哎放
Jack: When the time comes, just let it go.
Jake:这玩意标不了啦
Katrina: 理解不了
Katrina: Can't understand it.
Lucia:我们俩总有一个人模糊拍
Lucia: One of us always ends up blurry.
Jake:拍破防了 我草
Jake: The photo broke my defense, damn.
Lucia:对这张还行
Lucia: This one is okay.
Jake:拍到了吧是吧
Jake: Got it, right?
男嘉宾:ok
Male Guest: Ok.
Jake:反正我们是都录了
Jake: Anyway, we recorded everything.
男嘉宾:没电了
Male Guest: No battery.
Jake:噢
Jake: Oh.
Katrina: 摄影师不行了
Katrina: The photographer is done.
男嘉宾:看不见
Male Guest: Can't see.
Jack: 没事还有电而且还有好多电呢
Jack: It's okay, there's still battery, and plenty of it.
Jake: 挺好
Jake: That's good.
Lucia:对这张好像反光弱一些
Lucia: This one seems to have less reflection.
Jake:我觉得是第一个学习机里有接吻片的
Jake: I think this is the first learning device with kissing pictures.
Jake: 第一视角接吻照片
Jake: First-person kissing photos.
Jack: 我刚我刚错过了什么
Jack: What did I miss?
Jake:马上给他们看一眼
Jake: Let me show them quickly.
Jack: 我刚错过了什么
Jack: What did I miss?
Tasha: 这里面有 上一张
Tasha: It's in here. The previous one.
Shure:  对对对 上一张
Shure: Yes, yes, the previous one.
Jake:我们第一张图片配合第一张图片就是这个哇
Jake: Our first picture matches the first image, like this.
Jack: 让我看看 来来来先先
Jack: Let me see. Come on, come on, first first.
Tasha: 哦
Tasha: Oh.
Jack: 哦
Jack: Oh.
Katrina:  拍到了吗看看
Katrina: Did you get it? Let's see.
Jack: 哦
Jack: Oh.
Jake:啊好妙啊
Jake: Ah, this is brilliant.
Jack: 看了一下正点啊
Jack: I had a look, it's spot on.
Shure的女友:分手了只要钱到位也没关系
Shure's GF: Breaking up is fine as long as the money is right.
Katrina: 哇
Katrina: Wow.
Katrina: 哇 来给我拍一张
Katrina: Wow, come on, take a picture of me.
Lucia:对 我觉得这边这个好一点
Lucia: Yes, I think this one is better.
Jack: 分手一钱给到位也没问题
Jack: Breaking up is fine as long as the money is right.
Lucia:可以可以
Lucia: Okay, okay.
Nicous: 分手了也没有关系吗
Nicous: Breaking up is fine too?
Lucia:好的好的
Lucia: Okay, okay.
Katrina:  是发群里吧
Katrina: Should we post it in the group?
Katrina:  发群里公开
Katrina: Post it publicly in the group.
Jack: 没问题 没问题
Jack: No problem, no problem.
男嘉宾:全部都交给露亚了啊
Male Guest: Leave everything to Lucia then.
男嘉宾:什么时候导照片
Male Guest: When will the photos be uploaded?
女嘉宾:全部都交给露亚了啊
Female Guest: Leave everything to Lucia then.
Lucia:好好好我都
Lucia: Okay, okay, I'll do it.
Lucia:我都发到群里你可以建一个文件夹
Lucia: I'll post everything in the group, you can create a folder.
Lucia:然后我直接转发到群里
Lucia: Then I'll just forward it to the group.
Jake: 妙
Jake: Brilliant.
Nicous: 有点郁闷睡觉了
Nicous: Feeling a bit down, going to sleep.
男嘉宾:那看来是非常的复杂
Male Guest: It seems very complicated.
Lucia:可以可以
Lucia: Okay, okay.
Jack: 这关系真的是很复杂
Jack: This relationship is really complicated.
Lucia:可以发给我
Lucia: You can send it to me.
Tasha:啊
Tasha: Ah.
女嘉宾:可以发给我
Female Guest: You can send it to me.
Jake:抽两根要
Jake: Take two sticks.
Jack: 这Paty活动就是拍照
Jake: 该唱歌的人在那呢
Jake: The person who should be singing is over there.
Lucia:你还发了一个这个
Lucia: You also sent this.
男嘉宾:唱歌唱歌
Male Guest: Sing, sing.
Jake:该唱歌的人在这整活了
Jake: The person who should be singing is here doing something else.
Lucia:哎好看好看我觉得好看的
Lucia: Oh, it looks good, I think it looks good.
其他人：如果你想发的话就是不要发原图，发这张
Lucia:啊好的好的没问题不发原图
Lucia: Ah, okay, no problem, I won't send the original picture.
Shure: 我们要唱什么来着
Shure: What are we supposed to sing?
Shure: 是不是说说说给大家
Shure: Should we tell everyone?
Shure: 我的我的我的teammates
Shure: My, my, my teammates.
Shure:  我的我的roommates呢
Shure: Where are my roommates?
Shure:  roommates上里面调小药水去了
Shure: The roommates went to mix potions.
Jake: 这这你调酒去了
Jake: You, you're mixing drinks?
Jake: 你又唱
Jake: You're singing again.
Lucia:你有teammates吗？你不是说好了我自己solo吗
Lucia: You have teammates? Didn't you say you were going to solo?
Jake:solo 对呀
Jake: Solo, yeah.
Jake:solo dancer
Jake: Solo dancer.
Tasha: 可以可以
Tasha: Okay, okay.
Tasha: 没关系你想要哪张就哪张
Tasha: It's fine, you can choose any picture you want.
女嘉宾:给个这个吧
Female Guest: Give me this one.
Shure: 咋啦
Shure: What’s up?
Tasha: 我哪一张都可以
Tasha: Any picture is fine with me.
女嘉宾:我的脸都差不多
Female Guest: My face looks the same in all of them.
Tasha: 没关系我哪张都可以
Tasha: It’s okay, any picture is fine with me.
Shure: 不不上去还是在下边上去是吗
Shure: Are we going up or staying down here?
女嘉宾:好的好的
Female Guest: Okay, okay.
Jake: 哎都行听你的
Jake: Alright, whatever you say.
Jack: 都行啊
Jack: Alright, anything's fine.
女嘉宾:你从正面看
Female Guest: Look from the front.
Shure: 那下边中下边吧你去拿着吧
Shure: Then let’s stay down here, you hold it.
Jake: 行在下面呆着吧
Jake: Okay, stay down here.
Lucia:现在是
Lucia: Now it's
Lucia:7点 哇
Lucia: 7 o'clock, wow.
Lucia:已经都7:40了快
Lucia: It's almost 7:40 already.
Jake: 是
Jake: Yeah.
Lucia:这个可欣的guest
Lucia:啊 OK
Lucia: Ah, OK.
Lucia: 好像
Katrina:  他们俩个天天造我谣的
Katrina: They spread rumors about me every day.
Katrina:  我的roommates
Katrina: My roommates.
Shure:  所以我的iPad放哪了
Shure: So where did I put my iPad?
Shure:  哎 我的iPad
Shure: Oh, my iPad.
Shure:  谁记得我的iPad放哪儿
Shure: Who remembers where I put my iPad?
Shure:  我的iPad放哪儿
Shure: Where did I put my iPad?
Jake:会有这种数据我靠
Jake: There'd be data like this, damn.
Shure:  你有印象吗
Shure: Do you have any idea?
Lucia:你试试那个寻找我的iPhone的功能
Lucia: Try using the Find My iPhone function.
Jake: 哦你在找吗
Jake: Oh, are you looking for it?
Lucia:不是
Lucia: No.
Shure: 没有我的iPad
Shure: I can't find my iPad.
Lucia:修硕不是找不到
Lucia: Shure can't find it.
Shure:  忘记了放哪了
Shure: I forgot where I put it.
Lucia:我说可以试试寻找我的iPhone的功能
Lucia: I said you can try using the Find My iPhone function.
Jake: 咋的呀
Jake: What's up?
Jake: 不是这个不是这个薇薇的
Jake: No, this isn't Tasha's.
Lucia:这个应该是薇薇的吧
Lucia: This should be Tasha's, right?
Jake: 二楼没有吗
Jake: It's not on the second floor?
Shure:  你有看到我的iPad吗
Shure: Did you see my iPad?
Shure的女友:在楼上
Shure's GF: It's upstairs.
Shure: 是吗 你看到啦
Shure: Really? You saw it?
Shure:  哦哦在架子上呢
Shure: Oh, oh, it's on the shelf.
Shure: 对对对对
Shure: Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Shure的女友:不是 在在在在那个水池旁边
Shure's GF: No, it's by the sink.
Lucia:这两天这个网怎么老是这么差
Lucia: Why has the internet been so bad these last two days?
Jake:是我也发现了
Jake: Yeah, I noticed that too.
Katrina: 去二楼活动还是去哪活动啊
Katrina: Are we going to the second floor or somewhere else for activities?
Jake:二楼活动
Jake: Second floor activities.
Jake:或者外面都行
Jake: Or outside, it's fine.
Jake:看设备在哪
Jake: Depends on where the equipment is.
Katrina: 准备
Katrina: Get ready.
Katrina: 上才艺
Katrina: Show your talent.
Katrina: 撤退
Katrina: Retreat.
Katrina: 什么撤退了
Katrina: What retreat?
Lucia:哎你今天回学校吗
Lucia: Hey, are you going back to school today?
Katrina: 哦快8点了
Katrina: Oh, it's almost 8.
Katrina: 因为我们整体活动往后延了一个小时
Katrina: Because our whole activity was delayed by an hour.
Jake:我们不是6:40准时
Jake: Weren't we supposed to start at 6:40 sharp?
Jake:4.07准时开始是吗
Jake: 4:07 sharp, right?
Lucia:为什么大家都站着我坐着
Lucia: Why is everyone standing while I'm sitting?
Katrina: 上二楼坐
Katrina: Let's go sit on the second floor.
Jake:嗯没事没事
Jake: Hmm, it's okay, it's okay.
Lucia:起立
Lucia: Stand up.
Katrina: 上二楼坐一会你在走
Katrina: Go sit on the second floor for a bit before you leave.
Katrina: 那你那你明天还来吗你们
Katrina: Are you coming back tomorrow?
Katrina: 工作人员
Katrina: The staff.
Katrina: 修硕说他明天不来了
Katrina: Shure said he won't be coming tomorrow.
Katrina: 嗯
Katrina: Hmm.
Shure: 我想今晚就
Shure: I want to...
Shure: 因为leader要找我
Shure: Because the leader wants to see me.
Jake:哎呀要上去了
Jake: Ah, we need to go upstairs.
Shure: 他在上面活动
Shure: He's doing activities upstairs.
Jack: 既然你们都已经计划完了
Jack: Since you guys have already planned everything...
Shure: 那在上面活动吧
Shure: Let's do the activities upstairs then.
Lucia:又没电了
Lucia: We're out of power again.
Shure: 来吧
Shure: Come on.
Shure: 虽然上面的氛围肯定稍逊色一点
Shure: Though the atmosphere upstairs might be a bit lacking.
Katrina: 加了点青提以后就
Katrina: Adding some green grapes would...
Katrina: 小红书 上面学的就是
Katrina: Learned it from Xiaohongshu, it's...
Katrina: 养乐多加青提
Katrina: Yakult with green grapes.
Jake:要插电板吗
Jake: Do we need a power strip?
Shure: 不用了
Shure: No need.
Jake:不用了 好嘞
Jake: No need, got it.
Nicous: 你音箱接上了没
Nicous: Did you connect the speaker?
Shure: 音箱他们都接一起了我记得
Shure: I think they connected all the speakers together.
Shure: 对插这个
Shure: Yeah, plug this in.
Jack: 这这个是个啥呀
Jack: What's this?
Shure: 这就是个声卡
Shure: This is a sound card.
Shure: 哎这要插线板
Shure: Ah, we need the power strip.
Shure: 谁把这个插线板拔下去了
Shure: Who unplugged the power strip?
Shure: 我打算就回去上两天班看看心情
Shure: I'm planning to go back to work for a couple of days and see how I feel.
Jake:我啊 拔下去的呀
Jake: I unplugged it.
Shure: 来吧来吧
Shure: Come on, come on.
Shure的女友:修
Unknown: Shure.
Shure: 哎
Shure: Yeah?
Shure: 要钱嗯
Shure: You want money, huh?
Shure: 你先
Shure: You first.
Shure: 谢谢你
Shure: Thank you.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Jack: 来我给你主持一波
Jack: Let me host for you.
Nicous: 听说你今晚不走了走了
Nicous: I heard you're not leaving tonight.
Shure: 我
Shure: I...
Jake:啊你还要走啊
Jake: Ah, you still want to leave?
Jake:你不能走啊
Jake: You can't leave!
Shure: 我不能走么
Shure: I can't leave?
Jake:你你也能走
Jake: You can leave too.
Shure: 我我主要
Shure: I, I mainly...
Shure: 我主要想
Shure: I mainly want to...
Jake:想干嘛想想毕业
Jake: Want to do what? Want to graduate?
Shure: 明天上班主要是
Shure: Mainly, I have to work tomorrow.
Nicous: 明天上班
Nicous: Work tomorrow?
Shure: 明天
Shure: Tomorrow...
Jake:来插线板
Jake: Get the power strip.
Shure: 因为
Shure: Because...
Shure: 其实再再呆一天
Shure: Actually, staying another day...
Shure: 我翘了一周班
Shure: I've already skipped a week of work.
Jack: 哦血亏2100 至少2100
Jack: Oh, that's a loss of 2100, at least 2100.
Shure: 没有没有
Shure: No, no.
Jake:带薪翘班还是啥
Jake: Are you skipping work with pay or what?
Jack: 你给他300一天网易少给他300一天
Jack: You pay him 300 a day, NetEase pays him 300 less a day.
Shure: 没有没有
Shure: No, no.
Jake:哦这么回事
Jake: Oh, I see.
Shure: 网易就150
Shure: NetEase only pays 150.
Shure: 我一天
Shure: I get 150 a day.
Jake:那你一直在我身上 对啊
Jake: So, you've always been with me. Right.
Lucia:哦 其实赚了
Lucia: Oh, actually, you made a profit.
Shure: 而而且
Shure: And, and...
Jake:对啊 那你回去干嘛
Jake: Right, then why go back?
Jake:那你回去干嘛
Jake: Then why go back?
Katrina: 明天待一天还有300呢
Katrina: Stay another day, you'll get another 300.
Shure: 也也也也有道理
Shure: Yeah, yeah, that's true.
Jack: 对啊那那那
Jack: Yeah, exactly.
Shure: 待一天吧待一天吧
Shure: Stay another day, stay another day.
Shure: 哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha.
Shure的女友:谁呀我啊
Violet: Who, me?
Katrina: 反正他说他也转正不了
Katrina: Anyway, he said he can't get a full-time position.
Shure的女友:啊
Violet: Huh?
Katrina: 回家已经签了三访了
Katrina: He's already signed three contracts at home.
Shure: 等一下等一下
Shure: Wait, wait.
Jack: 既然都不奔着转正了，那能摸就摸吧
Shure: 插线板
Shure: 来 来
Shure: Come on, come on.
Katrina: 何况这还300一天
Katrina: Besides, it's 300 a day.
Jack: 这鱼摸得越多，白嫖的就越多
Katrina: 嗯
Katrina: Yeah.
Jake:确实 就是雇大家来摸鱼了
Jake:你们带着眼镜就行
Jake: You guys just wear the glasses.
Shure: 来 我来我来
Shure: Alright, I'll do it.
Jake:干啥都行
Jake: Anything is fine.
Shure: 哎
Shure: Hey.
Shure: 插上了
Shure: It's plugged in.
Katrina: 拍一下我们老板
Katrina: Take a picture of our boss.
Katrina: 哈哈哈拍一下我们提倡摸鱼的老板
Katrina: Haha, take a picture of our boss who encourages slacking off.
Katrina: 哈哈哈真好人
Katrina: Haha, such a nice person.
Katrina: 睡到11点不带叫你醒的
Katrina: Sleeping until 11 without waking you up.
Jack: 是吗
Jack: Really?
Jack: 喂喂
Jack: Hello, hello.
Jake:咦 少个人少人是吧
Jake: Hey, we're missing someone, right?
Jake:坐地上可以
Jake: Sitting on the floor is fine.
Katrina: 少谁啊
Katrina: 薇薇啊
Katrina: Tasha?
Jake:对
Jake: Yeah.
Katrina: 哦还有那个
Katrina: Oh, and that...
Katrina: 柯欣是吗
Katrina: Kexin, right?
Jake:柯欣
Jake: Kexin.
Jake:坐地上
Jake: Sitting on the floor.
Shure: 来吧我在703
Shure: Come on, I'm in room 703.
Katrina: 哈哈哈我们没有排过任何一遍
Katrina: Haha, we haven't rehearsed any of this.
Katrina: 真的的可以吗
Katrina: Really, is it okay?
Shure: 可以
Shure: It's fine.
Jake:这是默契
Jake: It's called chemistry.
Jake:已经毕业了
Jake: We've graduated.
Shure: 对就是默契
Shure: Yeah, it's just chemistry.
Jake:对这是提前培养的默契
Jake: Yeah, it's pre-developed chemistry.
Katrina: 等等等薇薇他们回来要不要一起
Katrina: Wait, should we wait for Tasha and the others to come back?
男嘉宾:难忘今宵
Male Guest: Unforgettable Tonight.
男嘉宾:不如在这个时候
Male Guest: How about now?
Shure: 来吧
Shure: Come on.
Shure: 我的我的我的朋友就是
Shure: My, my, my friend, it's...
其他人：你不会要唱难忘今宵吧
Shure: 不是不是不是
Shure: No, no, no.
Shure: 首先有一个我们这个这个
Shure: First, there's something for our EGO life family.
Shure: EGO life大家庭集体要完成的一个任务
Shure: It's not a task, it's a special program for everyone.
Shure: 叫做哎不是任务给大家
Shure: Called, uh, it's not a task, it's a show.
Shure: 准精心准备的一个节目叫做晴天啊
Shure: It's a carefully prepared show called "Sunny Day."
Shure: 想必大家都听过
Shure: I'm sure everyone has heard of it.
其他人：你们不是要合作嘛
Lucia:啊
Lucia: Ah
Lucia:噢
Lucia: Oh
Tasha:你就扶着凳子
Tasha: Just hold onto the chair
Shure: 没错没想到吧
Shure: Didn't see that coming, huh?
Lucia:没事 现在不是还没开始吗
Lucia: It's okay, it hasn't started yet, right?
Jack: 来吧谁唱谁主唱
Jack: Come on, who's singing lead?
Lucia:我拿个纸
Lucia: I'll grab a paper
Jack: 你主唱你就拿着话筒
Jack: If you're the lead singer, you hold the mic
Jack: 我拿话筒你
Jack: I'll hold the mic
Nicous: 你拿话筒你不主唱你拿话筒
Shure: 就是
Shure: Exactly
Nicous: 没有伴奏我是找不着调的
Shure: 那个凳子帮我往前放一点
Shure: Move the chair forward a bit for me
Katrina: 好一起唱呗
Katrina: Okay, let's sing together
Shure: 来吧大家会的就一起唱
Shure: Come on, everyone sing along if you know it
Katrina: 给你拍个绝美
Katrina: Let me take a beautiful picture of you
Lucia:你要擦那个相机吗还是
Lucia: Do you want to wipe the camera or...
Shure: 喂
Shure: Hello
Shure: 完了
Shure: Done
Katrina: 好 好听
Katrina: Okay, sounds good
男嘉宾:少个字
Male Guest: Missing a word
Katrina: 哎 可以
Katrina: Eh, it's okay
Tasha:嗯  好
Tasha: Hmm, alright
Shure: 对着点我嘴
Shure: Aim it at my mouth
Shure: 话筒一点升收不进去
Shure: A bit higher, it's not picking up
Jack: ok ok哥对不起
Shure: 哈哈哈喂喂哎
Shure: Hahaha, hello, hello, hey
Jake:哦忘词是吧
Jake: Oh, forgot the lyrics, huh?
Jake:在大屏幕上放词
Jake: Put the lyrics on the big screen
Katrina: 这是这是
Katrina: This is, this is
Katrina: 这是彩排啊
Katrina: This is a rehearsal, right?
Shure: 哈哈哈刚才是试音好吧
Shure: Hahaha, we were just doing a sound check, okay?
男嘉宾:主要是试音
Male Guest: Mainly a sound check
Shure: 好吧也也能看到
Shure: Okay, well, you can see it too
Katrina: 试音
Katrina: Sound check
男嘉宾:他这个看不到词
Male Guest: He can't see the lyrics
男嘉宾:对对对
Male Guest: Yeah, yeah, yeah
Shure: 也也能看到
Shure: Well, you can see it too
Nicous: 这词有点小
Nicous: The lyrics are a bit small
男嘉宾:大
Male Guest: Big
男嘉宾:可以可以
Male Guest: It's fine, it's fine
Shure: 可以看到可以看到啊
Shure: I can see, I can see.
男嘉宾:可以看到可以看到
Male Guest: I can see, I can see.
Katrina: OK
Katrina: OK.
Katrina: 那你要面对这边面吗
Katrina: Do you want to face this way?
男嘉宾:那你可以重来还是接着来
Male Guest: Can we start over or continue?
Shure: 从头来
Shure: Start over.
男嘉宾:从头来从头来
Male Guest: Start over, start over.
Katrina: 好
Katrina: Okay.
Shure: 保证
Shure: I promise.
Katrina: 有勇气
Katrina: Courageous.
Lucia:没事没事这个不是玻璃
Lucia: It's okay, it's okay, this isn't glass.
Shure: 啥玩意碎了
Shure: What broke?
Lucia:这是个啥呀
Lucia: What is this?
女嘉宾:杨老板杨老板
Female Guest: Jake, Jake.
Jake:呃给我给我就好了
Jake: Uh, give it to me, it's fine.
Lucia:ok ok
Lucia: Okay, okay.
Jake:对对
Shure: 故事的小黄花  从出生那年就飘着  童年的荡秋干  随记忆一直晃到现在  Re So So Si Do Si La   So La Si Si Si Si La Si La So   吹着前奏望着天空  我想起花瓣试着掉落  为你翘课的那一天  花落的那一天  教室的那一间  我怎么看不见  消失的下雨天  我好想再淋一遍
Shure: 没想到失去的勇气  我还留着好想再问一遍  你会等待还是离开
Shure: 刮风这天我试过握着你手
但偏偏雨渐渐大到我看你不见
还要多久我才能在你身边
等到放晴的那天也许我会比较好一点
Shure: 从前从前有个人爱你很久
但偏偏风渐渐把距离吹得好远
好不容易又能再多爱一天
故事的最后你好像还是说了拜拜
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Shure: 下一首还有还有下一首
Shure: Next song, there's another one, there's another one.
Nicous: 加个钢琴
Nicous: Add a piano.
男嘉宾:还有下一首
Male Guest: There's another song?
Katrina: 你想弹什么你弹
Katrina: Play whatever you want.
Nicous: 前面加一个钢琴
Nicous: Add a piano in the beginning.
Katrina: 来啊
Katrina: Go ahead.
Jack: 可以
Jack: Sure.
Jack: 流沙
Jack: Quick.
Shure: 我们是不是还说要唱new boy来着啊
Shure: Weren't we going to sing "New Boy"?
Katrina: 都行都行
Katrina: Anything's fine.
Katrina: 反正发现就还是咱几个人
Katrina: Anyway, it's just us here.
男嘉宾:唱什么
Male Guest: Sing what?
Katrina: 那随便唱
Katrina: Just sing whatever.
Shure: 来吧
Shure: Go ahead.
Jake:对都在掌握中
Jake: Yeah, it's all under control.
Jake:你随便唱
Jake: Sing whatever you want.
Katrina: 一切都在掌握中
Katrina: Everything's under control.
Shure: 那个XBZ你
Shure: Hey, XBZ, you...
Nicous: 你把麦关了
Nicous: Turn off your mic.
Shure: 你 你弹一个D调的卡农的和弦会吗
Shure: Can you play Canon in D?
Nicous: 可以
Nicous: Sure.
Shure: 不不 你就弹D调卡农和弦就行
Shure: No, just play the chords of Canon in D.
Katrina: 一切都在掌握中
Katrina: Everything is under control.
Nicous: 很高级
Nicous: Very advanced.
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Shure: 就是
Shure: Exactly.
Katrina: 就么看我房间还是很好看的哈哈
Katrina: Look, my room still looks pretty good, haha.
Shure: 找一下吧
Shure: Let's find it.
Shure: 哎呀歌词就行
Shure: Hey, lyrics would do.
Shure: 这个
Shure: This one.
Shure: 让大家
Shure: Let everyone...
Jake:对是其他挺费劲的
Jake: Yeah, the other stuff is quite tricky.
Shure: 能能能找明白不
Shure: Can you find it?
Shure: 啊
Shure: Ah.
Nicous: 是这个吗
Nicous: Is it this one?
Shure: 差不多吧
Shure: Pretty much.
Shure: 相信你
Shure: I trust you.
刘婷:怎么顶格了
Liu Ting: Why is it aligned?
Shure: 第一个是这个
Shure: The first one is this.
Shure: 拍什么曲子
Shure: What song are we filming?
Jake:哎薇薇呢
Jake: Hey, where's Tasha?
Shure: new boy
Jake:又翘班了
Jake: Skipping work again.
Shure: 好好好
Shure: Alright, alright.
Jake:不行不行
Jake: No, no.
Jake:翘班不行
Jake: Skipping work is not okay.
Shure: 来吧
Shure: Come on.
Jake:得上来摸鱼
Jake: She should be here.
Jake:翘班不行
Jake: Skipping work is not okay.
Shure: one
Shure: One.
Shure: two
Shure: Two.
Shure: one two three
Shure: One, two, three.
Shure: 是的我看见到处是阳光
快乐在城市上空飘扬
新世纪来得像梦一样
让我暖洋洋
Shure: 打这个是吗
Shure: Is it this one?
Shure: 这个这个
Shure: This one, this one.
Shure: 我从这调
Shure: I'll adjust from here.
Shure: OK 好
Shure: OK, good.
男嘉宾:喂
Male Guest: Hello.
Shure: 好
Shure: Alright.
男嘉宾:还有点大
Male Guest: Still a bit loud.
男嘉宾:稍为有点大得调小点
Male Guest: It's a bit loud, needs to be adjusted.
Shure: 好好好
Shure: Okay, okay, okay.
Shure: 你的老怀表还在转吗
你的旧皮鞋还能穿吗
这儿有一支未来牌香烟
你不想尝尝吗
明天一早
我猜阳光会好
我要把自己打扫
把破旧的全部卖掉
哦这样多好
快来吧奔腾电脑
就让它们代替我来思考
穿新衣吧剪新发型呀
轻松一下windows98
打扮漂亮
18岁是天堂
我们的生活甜得像糖
穿新衣吧剪新发型呀
轻松一下windows98
以后的路不再会有痛苦
我们的未来该有多酷
Katrina: 差不多 嗯
Katrina: Almost, yeah
Shure: 行了行了行了可以了可以了
Shure: Alright, alright, that's enough
Katrina: 哈哈哈谱还没对象
Katrina: Hahaha, still no date
Katrina: 结束了
Katrina: It's over
Shure: 来吧你你的难忘今宵了吧该
Shure: Come on, it's time for your unforgettable night
Shure: 哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha
Jack: 啊 谁难忘今宵了
Jack: Ah, whose unforgettable night?
Nicous: 那你调下声
Nicous: Adjust the volume
Shure: 来吧
Shure: Let's go
Shure: 人呢还有一个
Shure: Where's the other person?
Shure: 还有一个XBZ同学要为大家带来的一首歌曲
Shure: There's another student, XBZ, who will bring us a song
Shure: 叫
Shure: Called
Nicous: 谢彬竹和修硕的
Nicous: Xie Bin Zhu and Shure's
Shure: 没有我没有我
Shure: Not me, not me
Nicous: 你这比我重要了
Nicous: You're more important than me
Shure: 这个
Shure: This
Shure: 我比你重要什么
Shure: How am I more important?
Shure: 我给你选一个好听的音色就好了
Shure: I'll just pick a nice tone for you
Nicous: 给我切换一下
Nicous: Switch it for me
Shure: 好
Shure: Sure
Nicous: 用手指切换
Nicous: Switch with your finger
Shure: 来吧XBZ同学
Shure: Come on, XBZ
Shure: 没有他
Shure: He's not here
Katrina: 呵呵 这弹出来
Katrina: Haha, this pops out
男嘉宾:有点想哭了 音乐出来就想哭
Male Guest: Feeling like crying, the music makes me want to cry
刘婷:我吃饱了
Liu Ting: I'm full
Katrina: 这是背景音吧
Katrina: Is this background music?
男嘉宾:这加了特效音乐
Male Guest: They added special effects to the music
Katrina: 天呐 如听仙月耳在鸣哈哈
Katrina: Oh my god, sounds like heavenly music, haha
Jack: 准备 准准备开哭
Jack: Get ready, get ready to cry
Katrina: 这什么歌
Katrina: What song is this?
男嘉宾:难忘今宵
Male Guest: Unforgettable Night
Katrina: 啊
Katrina: Ah
Shure: 今夜我们在此欢聚
Shure: Tonight we gather here
Alice:我靠
Alice: Oh my god
男嘉宾:哎哟喂
Male Guest: Oh wow
Katrina: 说不清
Katrina: Can't explain it
Shure: 今夜我们在此快乐
Shure: Tonight we are happy here
Nicous: 再再来一点
Nicous: A little more
男嘉宾:已经开饮一天了
Male Guest: I've been drinking for a day already.
Alice:这什么环节啊
Alice: What is this segment about?
Katrina: 忘记今宵
Katrina: Forget tonight.
Shure的女友:难忘今宵
Shure's GF: Unforgettable tonight.
Jake:赶上clothing了
Jake: Just in time for clothing.
Shure: 我们相聚一堂
Shure: We're all gathered here.
Shure: 在这ego house
Shure: At this ego house.
Jack: 什么呀
Jack: What is this?
Alice:有点抽象
Alice: It's a bit abstract.
Jake:我跟你哈哈哈哈
Jake: I'm with you, hahaha.
刘婷:ego house
Liu Ting: Ego house.
Jack: 顺间就服气了
Jack: Suddenly, I'm convinced.
女嘉宾:你们坐吧
Female Guest: You guys sit down.
Alice:哦对我的衣服没晾哦
Alice: Oh right, I haven't hung up my clothes.
Shure: 我们难忘今宵
Shure: We will never forget tonight.
Alice:晾个衣服
Alice: Hanging up the clothes.
Shure: 我们难忘未来
Shure: We will never forget the future.
Jack: 难忘未来什么
Jack: Never forget the future, what?
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈你忘什么东西
Jake: Hahaha, what did you forget?
男嘉宾:我笑死了
Male Guest: I'm dying of laughter.
Alice:我笑死了
Alice: I'm dying of laughter.
Katrina: 还没过呢就难忘
Katrina: We haven't even finished yet and it's unforgettable?
Alice:难忘未来可还行
Alice: Unforgettable future, really?
Shure: 我们憧憬未来
Shure: 我们难忘过去
Shure: We will never forget the past.
Katrina: 好夺目啊
Katrina: So dazzling.
其他人：赶紧进入主题吧
Shure: 来吧 朋友
Shure: Come on, friends.
Jake:快进门
Jake: Hurry, get inside.
Shure: 牵着你的手
Shure: Holding your hand.
女嘉宾:要退票了
Female Guest: I want to return the ticket.
Shure: 就让
Shure: Just let...
Shure: 昨天的烦恼都忘掉
Shure: Forget all the worries of yesterday.
Shure: 去迎接明天的快乐吧
Shure: And embrace the happiness of tomorrow.
Katrina: 在做心灵SPA啊
Katrina: Doing a spiritual spa?
Shure: 啊
Shure: Ah.
Jack: 还啊的一声
Jack: Even made an "ah" sound.
Alice:我的天
Alice: Oh my god.
Shure: 多好啊
Shure: How nice.
Shure: 哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha.
Nicous: 我有点感觉这个谱子不太对啊
Nicous: I kind of feel this tune is off.
Shure: 挺好的
男嘉宾:没有
Jake:这叫离谱你懂吗
Shure: 这个我们就叫做离谱对吧
Jack: 没有
Jack: 滚你这看起来就不算有谱不能叫离谱
Alice:嗯
Nicous: 他没有背歌词
Nicous: 他在玩茶流鸡我草
Jack: 刚才应该已经醉了
Jake:哈哈已经唱完了
Shure: 没有没有我们这就是诗朗诵环节
Jake:哎好好好
Shure: 难忘今宵表演者
Shure: Ego life全体成员
Jake:啥 哈哈
Katrina: 立的都爬了
Katrina: 哈哈哈哈
男嘉宾:所以所以你们这一个礼拜
女嘉宾:退票
男嘉宾:都是天天这么精神抨击过来的吗
Katrina: 哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha
Shure: 新来的朋友啊
Shure: A new friend, huh?
Shure: 我们每天都很快乐
Shure: We're happy every single day.
Shure: 来吧快来到美好的ego life吧
Shure: Come on, join the wonderful ego life.
Jack: 美好啊是没有好那个好吧
Jack: Wonderful? More like not-so-wonderful.
Shure: ego life是一个
Shure: Ego life is a...
Shure: 快乐的大家庭
Shure: ...happy big family.
Shure: 是一个没有纷争的大家庭
Shure: A big family with no conflicts.
Lucia: 这咋听着越来越像传销啦
Shure: 是一个完蛋
Shure: It's a, oh no...
Shure: 我被美女包围了的大家庭
Shure: ...a big family where I'm surrounded by beauties.
Shure: Ego life
Shure: Ego life.
Jack: 就这句话比较现实
Jack: Now that's more like reality.
Shure: 带给了我快乐
Shure: It brings me joy.
Katrina: 这是诗歌朗诵
Katrina: Is this a poetry reading?
Shure: 带给了我金币
Shure: It brings me gold coins.
Jake:Ego Coin
Jake: Ego Coin.